so for those who don't know we wrote our
first book and it finally comes out next
week On January 15 when I say we I mean
a good friend of mine who runs a YouTube
channel legends of history who is a very
talented writer and myself now the
purpose of this video is to go with the
book in some more detail so those who
are new to the channel and those who may
be on the fence wanting some more
information before they purchase the
book now have that information to start
the book is called Greek mythology
explained which has definitely caused
some confusion as some people took that
to mean that the book would be a deep
analytical dive into Greek mythology
itself which isn't really what we were
going for the title more so relates to
the channel name there are still
explanations of each story historically
in contextually with an insight into
what we were thinking as writers but the
main focus of the book is the retelling
of six stories that we've chosen
almost like an anthology these stories
are Odysseus and he's encounter with
Scylla the story of Lamia and how she
became a monster the rise and fall of
Bellerophon the events lead into
Medusa's transformation the fall of
Icarus and the tragic love story of
Artemis and Orion each one of these
stories is illustrated and then
accompanied by a brief explanation
portion so why exactly did we choose to
structure the book in this way for me
personally one thing that I've always
felt has been missing from these old
texts and books is immersion the works
of Homer
Hesiod Ovid and many other poets of the
time often feel like a summary of a
story when compared to the standards of
writing that we expect today at times it
can be quite hard to write to their
characters especially those we would
consider outside of the major figures
because they lack personality and that's
because the level of detail just isn't
there what we've tried to do is stay
true to these stories but also fill in
the huge gaps and give these characters
personalities motives aspirations fears
and an overall reason for the audience
to relate to them we've turned these
brief summaries and timelines into full
length coherent stories I think one of
the main reasons that more people don't
enjoy mythology is the fact that many of
these current texts only appeal to those
who already have an interest in
mythology now don't get me wrong these
texts and books are a great source of
information and historical context but
if it's not something you're interested
in then the likes of Homer's Iliad and
Hesiod's Theogony are never really going
to capture your imagination and emerge
you into a story it's much easier to
take an interest in a character when you
I must into a story as opposed to just
reading the list of things that they may
or may not have done whether you like or
dislike postie Jackson and Rick
Riordan's books they have a clear goal
and they certainly achieve that goal
they act as a gateway into mythology for
a younger audience and I know many
people who now love mythology because of
those books and that is what we've set
out to do of this book we wanted to
create this gateway into mythology for a
slightly older audience but also wanted
to create a book that appealed to the
already existed mythology fans present
in these stories that they most likely
would have heard of before but in a new
and exciting way shining new light on
characters they may have read about in
passing but don't really know you have
characters like medusa Bellerophon and
Lamia where they have these very
interesting stories but even in their
own myths and legends they seldom feel
like the main character which is why
we've told these stories from their
perspective because for the most part
the story does remain true to the source
material but the way you feel about the
story and the characters certainly
changes especially since so many of
these stories feel like a book in
themselves once you really delve into
them now as for the overall tone of the
book it's definitely not one that's for
children if at one end of the spectrum
you have Percy Jackson and at the other
you have a game the throne shall we say
we certainly lean more towards Game of
Thrones and that's because these stories
are an unfiltered retelling of Greek
mythology there's murder betrayal
revenge adventure jealousy love and sex
and pretty much everything that you
would expect from Greek mythology each
story is also illustrated by a different
artist which I feel does help set a
different tone but still ties the book
nicely together most of the art that
you've seen over the course of this
video will be in the book to summarize I
feel the book is an interest in and
unique read for all audiences whether
you love mythology or whether it's new
to you we are definitely looking forward
to seeing how you as an audience write
to the book and how you feel about our
interpretations and the overall
structure there will be a few live
streams in February where we discuss the
book almost like an online book club
where everyone can come in and share
their thoughts and ideas and we can get
your feedback to answer the last
question that I see asked quite often
will there be more books like this and
will they be about other mythologies to
be honest as of right now we don't
really know and we do have two more
books of our publisher but we haven't
really decided what they'll be yet so I
guess it depends on the success of the
first book
we are however working on our own
separate projects such as the dark world
series which most likely will be
published as a book and an audiobook
once it's finished so if you haven't
already checked that out then the first
episode Krampus night is up on the
channel and it was definitely a fun one
to record we are also working on our
teen slash young adult mythology based
series which is probably will all most
excited about right now and hopefully
book 1 will be ready for the summer but
we'll definitely keep you posted on that
one on a quick side note I'd like to
thank everyone for a great year last
year it's because of you that we have
the opportunity to write these books and
work on these projects and we never
wanted to create something that we
wouldn't read ourselves and I honestly
believe that you will love Greek
mythology explained and the future
projects that we have coming for those
who haven't ordered the book yet you can
get the Kindle when the hardcover
versions on Amazon and most major book
retailers the B link in the description
for those in the United States and those
outside can simply order it from their
countries Amazon page as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained but before we do part ways
I'll leave you with the trailer for the
book for those who haven't watched it
yet or for those who would like to watch
it again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you